the fat pride thing is a big thing now
too where you're like we have a health
problem in America and now we're like no
no you can't say doctors are not allowed
to say you're obese you don't want get
you don't want a body shame anymore body
shame that was invented by fat white
women in like
2018 that's real talk again if
somebody's able to attach a level of
offensiveness put you in Peril of being
ostracized and alien lasers oh I got
sued by one of those fat
models yeah cuz the problem is she was
out there say like this is healthy I
said no your blood types pudding like
that's not
healthy and she she said it caused her
irreparable damage mentally I'm like sh
no what's causing aable damage is your
liver right now trying to keep up with
the enzymes that are flowing through
your like sh this it's one thing to be
overweight it's another thing to tell
everyone no no you have to say that
everybody is beautiful and healthy the
problem is the LIE